so a lot of people might say that
working with two Paul rides is a dream
yes dream come true how is how is it for
you it was a dream come true I've got a
different road every day and delivered
to me like a little Chinese delivery you
know Oh a new road so that was very nice
also lots of giggles and Chinese
electric like Chinese food like a
Chinese delivery foot no no I am Paul
[Music]
great work good work there yeah I get a
different like number 49
[Laughter]
fun for you to be able to play both
sides of that personality cuz that you
know you don't often get to do two parts
very much so yeah it was a new challenge
and one of the things that I thought
when I was reading it
oh my god what a what a fun thing to try
and attempt yeah
did you was there anything that had to
pull from from Melissa people think that
the life of an actor is all very
glamorous but you know in order to be
the sort of down in the dumps version of
yourself was it a big jump for you well
I had to access parts of myself that are
actually a human being you're always you
know whenever you're whenever I'm
playing anybody I'm trying to think
about things in my life and draw from
that to create any kind of character and
a lot of the characters I seem to play
or regular guys that are just trying to
keep their heads above water also and
I'd like you to make a baseball cap out
of this after those are people to you
know when you caught us we bleed sure
it's Stardust that comes out but we are
instilling people in our own way well we
do believe but generally they are
blood packets that this security run in
some part of our body I mean it's like
yeah
how long did everybody really easy it
kind then we have we have standards it's
done how long did it take you guys to
get your dance number down pat and were
you rehearsing together quite a bit yeah
yeah yeah it was one of those I'm a bit
sad they didn't do sort of stars you
know Dancing with the Stars montages of
us at the end going well you know we had
a great run and um yeah better luck next
week and you know because we did a lot
of practicing and rehearsal yeah yeah
there was a great woman named Jenny who
taught us how to kind of dance in that
weird way with arms yeah and she's yeah
Jenny sure she choreographed it and
Vallon John who are the directors had
found a video of her and her husband
will who's an arcade fire doing dance
online and then tracked them down to get
her to work with us to sort of make a
kind of couples dance that came from
ideas we have so one of the moves in it
which is this powder cake is actually
Paul's daughter
that's her powder cake dance that's our
signature move
do you remember it's like stuck in your
head I was gonna do the end of it though
you know we do this we do that and it's
like memorize that dance so much much